you've tweeted 30 minutes of reading a
day equals yeah this whole video and
this it's cool to think about reading
like in an um as a habit and something
that accumulates he said 30 minutes of
reading a day equals 1 000 books in 50
years
i love like thinking about this like
chipping away at the mountain
uh can you expand on that sort of uh the
habit of reading how do you recommend
people read yeah yeah i mean it's it's
incredible if you do something
a little
of something every day
it compiles it compiles you know i
always think about like the people who
achieve these incredible things in life
these great like famous legendary people
they have the same number of days that
you do and it's not like they were doing
magical days they just
they got a little done every day
and that adds up
to
uh
to to a
you know monument you know they're
putting one brick in a day eventually
they have this building this legendary
building
so you can take writing someone who you
know there's two aspiring writers and
one doesn't ever write doesn't you know
manages to never you know zero write
zero pages a day and the other one
manages to do
uh
two pages a week
right not very much the other one does
zero pages a week two pages a week 98
of both of their time is the same
the other person just two percent
they're doing one other thing
one year later they have written they
write two books a year this prolific
person you know in 20 years they've
written 40 books they're one of the most
prolific writers of all time they're
right two pages a week
um sorry that's not true i was the only
two pages a day okay two pages a week
you're still writing about a book every
two years so in 20 years you've still
written 10 books also prolific writer
right huge massive writing career you
write two pages every sunday morning the
other person has the same exact week and
they don't do that sunday morning they
are a wannabe writer they always said
they could write they talk about how
they used to be here and nothing happens
right so it's
it's inspiring i think for a lot of
people who feel frustrated they're not
doing anything so reading is another
example
where um someone who reads uh
very you know doesn't read and someone
who's a prolific reader you know i
always think about like the tyler cowan
types i'm like how the hell
do you read so much it's infuriating you
know or like james clear puts out his
like uh his 10 favorite books of the
year 20 his 20 favorite books of the
year i'm like
20 favorites
like i'm trying to just read 20 books
like that would be an amazing year so
um
but the thing is they're not doing
something crazy and magical they're just
reading a half hour a night you know if
you read a half hour a night the
calculation i came to is that you can
read a thousand books in 50 years so as
someone who's 80 and they've read a
thousand books you know between 30 and
80 they are extremely well read they can
they can delve deep into many
non-fiction areas they can be you know
an amazing fiction reader avid fiction
reader
um and again that's a half hour a day
some people can do an hour half hour in
the morning audiobook half hour at night
in bed now they've read two thousand
books so um i i i think it's um
it's just it's just it's motivating and
you realize that a lot of times you
think that the people who are doing
amazing things and you're not you think
that there there's there's a bigger gap
between you and then there really is
um i on the reading front i'm a very
slow reader which is just just a very
frustrating fact about me um but i'm
faster with audio books uh and also i
just you know i'll just
it's just hard to get myself to read but
i've started doing audio books and i'll
wake up throw it on do it in the shower
brushing my teeth you know making
breakfast dealing with the dogs things
like that whatever until i sit down and
that's i can read uh i can read a book a
week a book every 10 days at that clip
and suddenly i'm this big reader because
i'm just while doing my morning stuff i
have it on and also it's just fun it
makes the morning so fun i'm like having
a great time the whole morning i'm like
oh i'm so into this book
so i think that you know audiobooks is
another amazing gift to people who have
a hard time reading
you